i can still remember him sitting in that
living room that night in 69 glued to
the tv
watching the soviets plant their red
flag on the moon
the tears were
rolling down his cheeks
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about for all mankind season 3 episode 2
which i enjoyed quite a bit the race for
mars is on all the potential factions
trying to get there first have been
established and we get a glimpse of the
changing of the guard at nasa
kind of because while margo's still in
charge but it's out with the old and in
with the new and it turns out that at
least one member of the new generation
is a sort of psycho stalker type there
are tensions inside the geyser network
and that has some of our heroes feeling
sorry for themselves it's just a
temporary thing though because there's a
new player in the game to shake things
up and they're handing out second
chances i'll get into everything that
happened right after this quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched the
second episode of for all mankind's
third season yet then this video won't
be for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it
game changer is the title of this week's
episode and that refers to dev iesa and
his aerospace company helios we learned
in the opening sequence of the first
episode that he is filthy rich and he
got that way when he made breakthroughs
in clean nuclear fusion energy with this
partner this was no small achievement
and it even helped to roll back the
effects of global warming in order for
it to be a viable source of energy they
have to mine helium-3 on the moon and
that put him in the business of going to
space the episode opens with karen being
taken out to a meeting with him in the
desert polaris disaster happened to be
at the perfect time for him and he makes
her an opening offer on her business
that's so generous it makes her
suspicious as they're talking she
realizes his company is developing a
methane engine and that means that
they're trying to get to mars but they
don't have time to make a ship of their
own and still be competitive with nasa
and the soviets who are both planning on
launching their mission in four years he
wants to buy the hotel and put these new
engines on it so that he can get into
the race in the process of trying to
make the deal he tells karen an
inspiring speech about his father that
explains why he's interested in the
first place and it seems like we can
probably take him at his word at this
point in the story and when all is said
and done she gets a great deal and he
gets a spaceship at jsc molly learns
through a memo that the higher-ups are
trying to gain more influence over her
office she goes looking for margot who
still isn't back from her trip and we
watch her complain to emma then she
decides to make a move she goes back to
her office calls in danielle tells her
she won't be the commander of mars 96
and it's clear that she's doing this to
strike back against margot she's doing
it when she's not there she's doing it
even though she told her that they would
talk whenever she got back and she knows
this will cause problems but the way
things are currently set up she still
has the ultimate authority and decides
to use it she laid out her reasons in
the premiere of why she thought that ed
was the better choice and she tells
danny the same thing she obviously
doesn't agree but doesn't have a problem
with running ed's backup crew molly goes
to tell him the good news and he's
beside himself he can't believe it and
he is really pumped up we catch up with
karen who's clearing out her office at
polaris and danny stops by while he's
there to pick up tracy's astronaut pin
from sans office she has to ask him why
he played the song at the reception and
he lies at first saying it was his
wife's idea and then leaves but turns
right back around and comes back in to
tell her that he lied he makes a play
telling her that he can't put it behind
him even after all these years and she
shuts it down in a way that doesn't
leave any room for misinterpretation she
even adds a little slap in there which
is a nice touch we get the idea that
there's a long history of this sort of
thing that when he was drinking he was
showing up to her house drunk and that
she thought that he had gotten over it
that he moved past it when he got sober
one thing that i thought was interesting
is that he brings up ed and it's clear
that he really doesn't like them
together it seems like him being worried
that they might get back together is a
part of what's happening right now she
doesn't want to have anything to do with
it and she tells him that he needs to go
home to his wife and he does eventually
leave
at their home ellen and larry are
discussing her idea of having john
mccain as her running mate and he's
against it he stresses that she needs to
get someone that's different that will
appeal to the base especially someone
who will bring in the evangelicals and
he does mention that at this point she's
behind bill clinton in the polls later
she'll have a meeting with this new
character governor bragg where she does
bring him on board but the real twist in
this scene is that ellen and larry have
a child it's a big surprise and they
have this nice interaction where they
seem like one big happy family at the
office danny and ed continue their
friendly rivalry you can tell that she's
devastated not to get the command but
she does back her friend up and
congratulate him for getting the mission
and we see them share a moment he goes
to call kelly and offers her a spot on
his crew we learned that he's ending his
marriage with yvonne and that this isn't
the first divorce that he's had after
karen i'm guessing it's the second but
the way she says it there could be more
i guess i thought it stood out that one
of the reasons that margot favored danny
was her interest in knowledge of science
and here we see kelly trying to tell her
father what she's doing in her research
and he really isn't even paying
attention danny comes home to tell her
husband that she didn't get the command
spot and after what happened on polaris
he's actually relieved we get to see her
at home with her family and things look
pretty good there but this all turns out
to be set up because when margot gets
back she learns from bill that molly
made her decision to name ed while she
was gone this leads to an interesting
confrontation margot is in charge of the
agency but knows that she can't force
molly to do what she wants molly is
throwing that in her face so she decides
that her only choice is to fire her and
it's the type of situation where you
don't like the choice but can absolutely
understand why she made it plus neither
one of them are exactly right for these
being two characters we like it's pretty
hard to get behind either one of them
and the way that they handled this
margot follows up by having the
conversation with ed to tell him that he
won't be going to mars he's
understandably devastated and angry and
essentially says that the pencil pushers
and the lab coats have finally taken
over again we can understand his
perspective here but molly's decision is
the one that created this situation and
they're gonna always side with each
other the two of them have a drink in
her office and discuss how their time
has passed and this reminded me of their
conversation when they were on the moon
searching for the ice about how they
were selfish and they were narcissistic
and you know what now they're getting
pretty old speaking of the moon we get a
quick look at elena arriving there and
it's a lot of fun to see her face but
also we get to see how jamestown base
has expanded over the last nine years
and it's pretty impressive overall it's
a pretty short visit but we do see her
call her father and it looks like he
might be starting to experience early
signs of dementia or something like that
this makes me think about how involved
her job is we've seen that margot who is
essentially her mentor doesn't have room
for the family life at all and now we're
getting hints that aleda's might be more
complicated than it appeared in the
first episode
ed and danny meet up at the now
corporate outpost which i don't think
anyone's happy about the changes they've
made to this place it seems like a
disney vacation kind of situation that
goes way beyond the ferns that karen
introduced in season two he's upset he's
drunk and insinuates that if it were a
level playing field that is if politics
and optics weren't involved he would be
the obvious choice which is a pretty
on-brand way to look at it by a guy like
him in that situation when you're always
used to being on top there has to be an
explanation when things go wrong some
external force working against you but
it goes beyond him just being a bad
friend because as viewers we know that
he's just wrong here none of what he's
talking about is responsible for why
they made this decision plus when the
shoe was on the other foot danielle got
behind him and we saw the bond they had
and it's that connection that she loses
as a result of him not getting his way
he drives over to karen's house drunk
and crashes into her gate and we see
that danny was outside in his car
watching her place which i don't even
know what to say about that she brings
him inside and cleans him up and they
talk about how they're getting older and
nothing is turning out the way they
thought it would i guess the most
important thing here is that it gives
her an idea and we see her go to helios
to talk to dev to try to convince him
they need someone like ed to command
their mission she finds out she doesn't
just need to convince him because they
run the business as a collective he
brings it up to everyone and after a
vote they decide to hire him on her way
out deb stops her to offer her a job
doing whatever she wants basically she'd
be recruiting people and at first she
isn't interested he picks up on the fact
that it's because of what happened with
the hotel and he gives her an inspiring
pep talk that brings her around and she
agrees to come on board back at nasa
margot tells danny that elena worked out
the glitch in the nerva engine they
talked crew wishlist and the idea that
ed was going to bring kelly comes up
before she tells margo she wants danny
stevens as her right seat and this makes
me really question the writer's decision
to name both of these characters danny
before they can discuss that nori comes
in and tells them to turn on the tv deb
is holding a press conference where he
announces that karen's now working for
helios then he explains their plan to
repurpose polaris by adding their
methane engines to take it to mars they
renamed it phoenix and they announced
that ed will be the commander of their
mission which will be launching in the
next window a full two years before nasa
and the soviets plan to launch their
missions in the end ed got what he
wanted and when you see him on that
stage you have to wonder if that might
not go to his head there's gonna be a
giant competition here he wants to get
there first because he's been living
with this regret that he had a chance to
be the first person on the moon but he
decided to follow his mission instead he
was just awful to a long time friend
with a totally incorrect and out of line
statement and danny is playing for the
home team so you can bet that nasa is
going to do everything in their power to
try to get her there first the soviets
might have real problems getting their
engine together two years sooner
everything we've seen so far seems to
indicate that they were gonna have
trouble getting it together for 96 and
that means that margot might end up in a
bad situation because of her covert
working relationship with sergey and
after seeing karen and ed up on that
stage together it's at least possible
that danny stevens might mutiny and
crash the sojourner one into the phoenix
just to take him out we kind of go
around and see everyone's reaction to
this as it's airing on tv and no one
seems all that hyped up except for molly
who we find smoking a joint in her
bathtub and the episode ends there a lot
of things are developing here and most
of it got me excited to see what happens
next debbayesa seems like a good
addition so far most signs point to him
being a positive force in at least
moving things forward regardless of the
effect that he has on humanity i mean
it's hard to take him at his word for
half of the stuff he's saying and their
office culture and all of that stuff
that you see there looks like great
ideas but it also looked that way
whenever google was just starting out
and in other big tech firms that didn't
turn out to really be a force for good
still most of the red flags come from
the system that gave birth to him and
the way billionaires generally behave in
our timeline i would say we don't know
enough to get a real read on how this
character will develop and that's a
pretty good place to be in his
introduction means timelines will change
and that nasa and the soviets will have
to try to keep up and that seems like
fertile ground for things to go wrong in
exciting ways karen and ed going over to
his company marks the end of an era as
far as things happening in a way that
we're used to nasa will have to lose a
lot of people in this process and it's
going to be the start of some brand new
dynamics that are going to affect the
series going forward things are going to
get shaken up and the way they kept
going back to this idea of everyone
getting older and things changing makes
you wonder how things will fall into
place it brought out a lot of
complicated feelings about the
characters and how we see them as well
as we know most of them they're all sort
of in unfamiliar territory one thing i
liked better about this episode was that
a lot of what i was thinking about in
the previous one and brought up in my
last video seemed to get addressed here
sometimes it was just indirectly but it
seems like things are moving in the
right direction that said danny kind of
went from bad to worse but at least now
he's a wild card for the mission they
did establish his talent we watched him
get brave and saved the day last week
and at the same time he's got this
unhealthy obsession for karen that can't
take him anywhere good it's the one
lukewarm story point for me right now
but there's time for it to turn around
to become something else and i think
that is a good place to leave things
let me know in the comments what you
thought about this episode how you feel
about the season so far and where you
think things are going next please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon